HE WAS INTERESTED WHAT THE
CRIMINAL WAS THINKING WHEN THE
CRIMINAL COMMITTED A VIOLENT
CRIME.
SO, THERE ARE ALL KINDS OF
ADDITIONAL EVIDENCE THAT WILL BE
GATHERED AT THIS POINT GOING
FORWARD.
SO WHEN YOU TRY A MURDER CASE,
YOU UNDERSTAND THAT YOU ARE
STILL INVESTIGATING UNTIL YOU
YOUR CLOSING STATEMENT AND I'VE
DONE IT MANY TIMES.
AS IT RELATES TO GENEALOGICAL
EVIDENCE, THEY LITERALLY CAN GET
EVIDENCE BACK TO 1800s.
IT IS NOT YOUR TYPICAL CODING.
YOUR TYPICAL PERSON WHO KNOWS
COATING AND DNA SAYS, "OKAY, IF
YOU ARE AT THE BANK AS A
CRIMINAL, OR DNA CAN BE MATCHED
TO WHAT IS IN THE BANK."
THE TRUTH IS, IF YOU'RE NOT A
CRIMINAL AND KOHBERGER COME AS
FAR AS I KNOW DOES NOT HAVE A
CRIMINAL RECORD, SO HE WOULD NOT
HAVE MATCHED IN THE DATABANK.
THEY WOULD THEN HAVE TO TAKE THE
BLOOD, NOT IF ANY OF THOSE FOUR
VICTIMS AND HAVE THAT BLOOD
ANALYZED.
THEN BUILD THE GENEALOGICAL TREE
FROM THAT.
SO THEY FIND OUT WHO WERE THE
RELATIVES?
ONCE THEY FIGURE OUT WHO THE
SUSPECT IS, THEY THEN START TO
INVESTIGATE, SPREAD OUT FROM
IDAHO TO PENNSYLVANIA.
AND THEY POPULATE HISTORICAL
DATA.
THIS IS GENIUS GOING ON.
SO COATING, 30% OF CASES, BUT
THIS GENEALOGICAL DNA GIVES US A
90% CHANCE OF SOLVING THESE
CASES.
SO IN ADDITION TO WHAT WILL BE
UNEQUIVOCAL, UNEQUIVOCAL, I
SHOULD SAY, EVIDENCE, THEY WILL
HAVE ALL KINDS OF FILMIC
CIRCUMSTANTIAL EVIDENCE IN
ADDITION TO WIND THE AFFIDAVIT
IS UNSEALED.
>> Kennedy: JUDGE COMMITTED IS
KENNEDY AND I HAVE A QUESTION
ABOUT WHAT LAWRENCE BROUGHT UP
AND THAT IS THE STATEMENT THAT
THIS PERSON ALLEGEDLY MADE TO
THE ARRESTING OFFICERS IN
PENNSYLVANIA.
AND THAT WAS, DID YOU ARREST
ANYBODY ELSE?
OBVIOUSLY, THAT COULD BE A RED
HERRING OF AN INTELLIGENT
SOCIOPATHS WITH THROW OUT IN
ORDER TO PROLONG AN
INVESTIGATION AND LITIGATION
POTENTIALLY.
BUT WHAT ARE THE CHANCES IN YOUR
ESTIMATION OF SEEING CASES LIKE
THIS THAT HE PERPETRATED THIS
ALONE?
>> LOOK, KENNEDY, I DON'T KNOW
THAT I CAN GIVE YOU AN ANSWER ON
THAT BECAUSE IT'S NOT GROUNDED
IN EVIDENCE YET.
BUT WHAT I CAN TELL YOU, THE GUY
IS CLEARLY A SOCIOPATHS.
BY THAT, HE IS CLEARLY SAYING.
ANYONE LISTENING, HE WILL NOT
GET AWAY WITH ANY KIND OF MENTAL
INSANITY.
BUT NUMBER ONE, BUT NUMBER TWO,
THE POLICE ARE LOOKING FOR ALL
THE OCCUPANTS OF A WHITE
HYUNDAI ELANTRA SO HE MAY BE
FEEDING INTO THAT.
WE DON'T KNOW WHAT HE MAY HAVE
SAID THAT HE THOUGHT INNOCENTLY
OTHER MEMBERS OF THE
HYUNDAI ELANTRA WILL NOW TAKE ON
A DIFFERENT MEANING.
>> Joe: THIS IS JOE CONCHA.
IT IS MIND-BOGGLING FEES FOR
MURDERS CARRIED OUT WHILE TWO
WHETHER SLEEPING THE ENTIRE
TIME.
SO I GO BACK TO KENNEDY'S
QUESTION BEFORE, WHICH IS THE
SUSPECT ASKED IF ANYONE ELSE WAS
ARRESTED.
IT IS HARD TO BELIEVE THAT HE
WAS ABLE TO.
THIS OUT ALONE.
IT WAS NOT A GUN COME OBVIOUSLY
USED TO KILL FOUR PEOPLE AND NO
ONE ELSE HEARS IT.
IT IS ALMOST AS IF HE WOULD NEED
HELP TO GET THIS DONE.
SO WHAT ARE YOUR THOUGHTS ON
THAT?
>> WELL, YOU KNOW, I ALWAYS
WONDERED ABOUT THAT.
BUT LET'S TALK ABOUT THE FACT
THAT, THEY'VE GOT THIS
GENEALOGICAL DNA SUPPLY SOURCES
WHICH IS SPOT ON.
IF ANYONE ELSE WAS CUT ON THE
SCENE, THAT PERSON'S BLOOD WOULD
BE IN THERE AND TRYING TO PUT IT
ALTOGETHER OR LOOKING FOR
SOMEONE.
BUT I DON'T KNOW.
THAT IS WHAT YOU CAN'T DO, YOU
CAN'T SPECULATE AT THIS POINT.
I ALWAYS THOUGHT IT WOULD TAKE
MORE, JOE, LOOK WHEN KIDS GO OUT
PARTYING AND IT'S A WEEKEND,
SATURDAY NIGHT, WHO KNOWS HOW
MUCH THEIR DRINKING AT THE
PARTY?
THE TOXICOLOGY AND MEDICAL
EXAMINER, THE CORNER DID